ce lundi 24 août les autorités ont
recensé les premiers cas de
contamination coronavirus au sein de la
population
quatre personnes d'une même famille dans
le camp de réfugiés d'al marasi dans le
centre de la bande de gaza depuis les
quatre contamination ne cesse
d'augmenter dans ce territoire
palestinien au système de santé fragile
les autorités gazaouies craignent de
perdre le contrôle
elles ont donc décidé de tester
davantage et de prendre de nouvelles
mesures
nous voulons étendre la période du
couvre feu et l'interdiction des
mouvements à l'intérieur et entre les
gouvernorats 72 heures et cela pourrait
être renouvelée afin de mieux surveiller
de préserver des vies de lutter contre
cette pandémie et d'identifier ceux qui
ont été en contact avec des personnes
infectées
la maladie de kovy 19 pourrait se
propager très vite dans l'enclavé
palestinienne lancer mon peuple est un
territoire sous blocus israélien déjà
privés d'électricité régulièrement
bombardée une situation qui inquiète les
autorités sanitaires de gaza
alia au darfour aujourd'hui avec toutes
les tentatives que nous avons fait nous
ne pouvons pas revenir à la case départ
car les portes par lesquelles le virus
pourrait entrer étaient nombreuses et
les foyers qui sont apparus étaient
nombreux donc je ne peux pas aujourd'hui
faire référence précisément et
spécifiquement à la source par laquelle
ce virus est entré dans la bande de gaza
coupés du monde depuis le début de
l'épidémie au mois de mars le territoire
palestinien était jusque là une des
rares zones épargnées par le virus dans
le monde
2 les autorités avaient réussi à éviter
l'importation de la maladie via des
mesures strictes toute personne entrant
dans la bande de gaza était soumise à
une quarantaine obligatoire de trois
semaines ces visiteurs étaient
systématiquement placés dans des centres
surveillés par les forces de l'ordre